the fire started overnight in freezing
temperatures in a plant that produces
Jet and fuel oil the sort of bman I got
a call at around 2:45 in the morning
from the regional governor who told me
about the fire at the novatech facility
in the Porto UGA shortly after
firefighters were called to the
site Ukrainian media reported the fire
erupted after a drone strike carried out
by Ukraine's Secret Service the
explosion analysts say May pose a
logistical and economic setback for
Russia which also exports fuel from that
gas terminal it could also lead to an
escalation because this brings the
Baltic Sea into play and there could be
repercussions because this could be lead
to Russia accusing the Baltic allies of
the uh ukrainians the NATO countries of
aiding and abating in this attack
Russia and Ukraine have targeted each
other's energy infrastructure to disrupt
supply lines and Logistics Moscow blames
keev for this attack on Friday it
happened at an oil facility in the Bon
region in South West Russia the company
that operates the plant says Sunday's
fire was a result of an external
influence but the Russian Ministry of
Defense hasn't confirmed if it was the
result of a drone attack
Lopez Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer